what the heck is ketogenic diet quickly
lose weight that's with benefits
speciate your appetite ketosis ketosis
butter is good explain yourself
the ketogenic diet let's break down what
all this hype is about I'm gonna tell
you what it is briefly how it works
and discuss some of the claims that are
most commonly made on the subject let's
get started before we get into the
ketogenic diet let's break down some
very simple nutrition basics there are
three major macronutrient groups that
we're gonna be paying attention to
proteins fats and carbs these are
nutrients that you find in the foods you
eat every single day the standard
American diet consists of 35% of fats
15% of proteins and 50% of carbs now if
you're looking at the ketogenic diet the
numbers are quite different with 75%
being fats 20% being proteins and only
5% being carbs think about that that's
10 times less carbs than than the
standard American diet
let's say you switch from your standard
diet to a ketogenic diet what happens
inside of your body your body deals with
this very low carb consumption in two
ways first it enters a state called
ketosis which shifts your body's energy
source to primarily fats which basically
means that it breaks down fats into
something known as ketones hence ketosis
and then uses those for energy simply
put your body begins to burn fat as its
primary energy source and moves away
from glucose which is a carbohydrate the
process of going into ketosis does take
a few days and during those days people
experience some adverse side effects
brain fog the irritability nausea GI
discomfort some people label this the
keto flu either feels so good the second
process your body uses is
gluconeogenesis which sounds scary but
it's really not all it is is your body
creating glucose because not all cells
can function on fats alone fun fact here
for survival purposes you don't need to
consume any carbs as long as you're
getting enough fats and proteins now
where did all of this hype for the
ketogenic diet come from let's take a
look at the claims and find out what's
true and what's not claim number one the
ketogenic diet is good for weight loss
yeah
the ketogenic diet is good for weight
loss and this happens through two
important mechanisms first since you're
using fats as your primary energy source
you're burning a lot of stored fat
second because fat is very satiating
makes you feel full when you eat a high
fat content meal you actually don't want
to eat as much therefore you limit the
amount of calories you take in
throughout the day a lot of people are
surprised that when they start the keto
diet that they lose weight very quickly
but that's a little misleading because
the majority of the weight loss
initially comes from water loss not fat
loss for those of you seeking long-term
weight loss the ketogenic diet is not
super sustainable it's graduation day
all your friends are going to get ice
cream
some of them are getting a cookies and
cream milkshakes and you can't have any
because you're on a keto diet that's
crazy you have to be super vigilant when
you're on the ketogenic diet because
carbs have this
nasty habit I'm just sneaking into your
foods ketchup high carb food
bananas cookies and cream milkshakes
well I just love cookies and cream
milkshakes and so much for having a
celebratory drink with your friends no
to alcohol claim number two the
ketogenic diet is good for the brain the
truth of the matter is the jury's still
out on this one because science hasn't
given us the answer the research on this
area just hasn't been completed yet
anecdotally some people say they feel
more focused or sharper one the
ketogenic diet but I've also heard from
patients of mine that they feel foggy ER
and that keto flu stays with them much
longer than anticipated so I don't like
using anecdotes as reasons why a certain
diet is good or not
I need a quality research which I just
don't have claim number three the keto
diet prevents or manages many chronic
diseases this is a yes and no answer
where keto diet really shines is in type
two diabetes because when you have type
2 diabetes you have insulin sensitivity
issues you have high sugar content in
the blood and research has shown over
and over again that the ketogenic diet
for type 2 diabetes works we have to
talk about childhood epilepsy because
that's where the keto diet actually got
its roots we can actually prescribe the
ketogenic diet to children who have
refractory epileptic seizures and what
we find is once they get into a state of
ketosis they have a decreased frequency
of these seizures it works it's proven
it's evidence-based science the
ketogenic diet has shown some promise in
the field of oncology aka cancer it's
not ready to be a primetime cancer
treatment just yet and the research
doesn't fully support it to be a
preventive measure for developing cancer
but what we do know is that some promise
is there and more research needs to be
done
some harms that can stem from following
a ketogenic diet nutritional
deficiencies from cutting out large food
groups an increase in your bad LDL
cholesterol kidney issues bone issues
and even the increase of some certain
cancers when you're overeating foods
like processed or red meats my final
thoughts on the keto diet I think it's a
good diet for weight loss I think it's
better for short-term weight loss than
long-term weight loss so if you have a
wedding that you're getting ready for
some kind of big event that's upcoming
and you're otherwise healthy I don't
think it's a bad diet to go on the fact
that the diet is very difficult to
adhere to because of how much you have
to drastically change your eating
patterns of the possible adverse effects
that can come from following the diet
and frankly from the lack of knowledge
and the lack of research we have on its
long-term effects all put into question
and really encouraged me to not
recommend this diet to the majority of
my patients and to you at home I've read
in the comments that some of you want me
to try the keto diet now if you get this
video to 20,000 likes I will try the
keto diet and I'll take you on the
journey along with me as always stay
happy and healthy we have to talk about
childhood epilepsy because that's where
the keto diet actually got its roots
found its roots began its roots it
shino's syndrome i don't know how to do
these do i do it the whole time I said
keto flu the keto flu settle down there
is it weird to be just pops into frame
[Music]